hand-using silver, colloidal silver, as a mouthwash, killed a good bacteria in the mouth and got.
That's a good question because you do have good microbiota in your mouth every orifice of
your body, even on the outer side surface of your body, you have microbiota. That's the negative of
using these hand-cleaders that came out during COVID. They're not good for you. They just disrupt
your normal lura. They disrupt your microbiota even internally. You absorb them. They're chemicals.
Now you're dealing with oxidative stress from that. It's just poison. So I'm not in favor of doing that.
Hand-using colloidal silver, or using even oregano oil in your mouth like our tooth and gum
oil with the black seed oil. Can you see the different both washes that we sell in the store?
Disrupt the lura, the microbiota in your mouth. It can. You will never kill all of it, but what you're
trying to do is you're trying to knock down the overgrowth of pathogenic microbiota.
So like the one that we have from the company biosited, biosited is a great company. They formulated
their mouthwash. That's the one I use. I think that one's the best for dental issues.
Now they just came out with that last year, and they have a whole dental protocol. You do it for
two months and so. But using colloidal silver, I don't think you're going to throw off your microbiota
the martyred old fixer.